he was a monster
the founding father of gilead
he took away our country
he had to pay for what he did
i killed him
and i loved it so much
[Music]
june tore him apart
i need her to know with me
do you want her to come after us
there's no way that she could have
gotten to fred on her own
serena doesn't know what happened
it doesn't matter what she knows
matters what she believes
serena has the world behind her
she is bringing it here
dalian
my job is to protect you
tell me you can protect me from her
scare can be very dangerous she will
always be dangerous
i think you scared gilead as well
the handmaid killing her commander
i don't think they'll be able to let
that stand
june osborne is a cancer
we have to cut her out
there are consequences for disobeying
god
gilead wants to see us suffer you have
to keep yourself safe
[Music]
everything we want to know about hannah
it's right there
they're not gonna be looking for
somebody going back into gilead
i'm going i'm going with you
[Music]
fear you're careful
she will pull you down with her
i pray for our children
may they live a life without all of this
hate
[Music]
dear
god may they do better than we did
[Music]
you